لش صعب صعب كثير والاصعب انك انت ما تلاقي
جثامين الاخر بقول الارواح صعدت الى
السماء اتتهم مره على
البحر كانوا زهقانين اتتهم بعد العصر
وصفنا صلينا المغرب وروحنا يومها كان الحس
صوت مع لانهيت في السنه بالحجه بعد
الصلاه بقول له علي صوتك ما سمعنا ايش
[موسيقى]
بتقرا انا مؤمن شرافي صحفي فلسطيني من غزه
بعمل في الجزيره منذ ما يقر 12 سنه انا
كنت انا زميلي حمدان بغطي ماخذين شف الليل
بنغطي تقريبا الساعه ار 4 الفجر اخر نشره
كانت الساعه اعه الفجر بعد ما خلصت
اللايف يعني كان قلبي قبضني يعني حاسس في
شيء غريب بقول لحمدان انا مخنوق
متضايق في شيء حاسس في شيء صاير بس انا مش
عارف ايش هو عملنا نشره خمسه طلعنا اللايف
خمسه ونص وصل عاجل انه
في قصف اسرائيلي على بلوك اثنين في مخيم
جباليا على الفور اتصلت حاولت اتصل
اتصالات كانت صعبه اتصلت في ابن اخوي
الموج
فصرات لانه في بلوك اثنين موجود بيت خالتي
انا بدي اطمن على خالتي مش على اهلي
بالاساس بقول له في بلوك اثنين صار في قصف
وفي شهداء عدد كبير من الشهداء طمنت على
خالتي
صباح سكت ابن اخويا بقوله ليش مالك سكتت
قاللي الليله دار سيدي اللي هو ابويا الحج
والحجه واخويا الدكتور ايمن وعائلته زوجه
عمار وعائلته
واطفالها اولاد اختي وخلاتي يعني عشاء
كانوا واصلين قبل القصف بعد صلاه العشاء
كانوا واصلين البيت هذا بعد بساعات عه ونص
خسه الفجر اي تم قصف المنزل برميل متفجر
يعني 21 فرد تقريبا في هذا البيت تم
استهدافه بشكل مباشر الحاج كان مدرس تاريخ
خدم في سلك التعليم تقريبا مايقرب اكثر من
35 سنه والحاجه كمان كانت معلمه خدمت ما
يقارب 30 سنه اي
اي فقدت جزء كبير كبير كبير بخصوص امي على
وجه
التحديد الدعاء
الرضا بتحس حتى لو كنت بتغطي في حرب وخطر
بتحس في انه في شيء من الله رعايه الله
بتحف فعل دعواتها
ورضاها صوتها كان امان بمثابت امان اكثر
من الدرع والخوذه واكثر من اي شيء نحن
كصحفي بحاول نكون
فيها القصف احدث حفره ماقرب من خمسه لست
امتار ما فيش ركام ما فيش جثامين انت ما
يقلقك الان انك انت تبحث عن جثمان اي حدا
من
21 لتكرم وتدفنه ليرتاح قلبك وابرد قلبك
وسلم الامر لحن مسلمين طبعا بقضاء الله
وقدره الحج ما يقارب عمره تجاوز 887 عام
عايش نكبه فلسطين عام 48 اي كان عمره
تقريبا 12 سنه كل ما يحكي لنا تفاصيل
الهجره والنكبات هجير في 48 كانه بيوصف
لنا مشهد سينمائي بادق ادق ادق التفاصيل
هذه التجربه
والعقل اللي تركت في عقليته في عقله وفي
ذهنه تاع 48 رفض يكررها في 2023 ورفض فكره
النزوح ابدا من غز والشمال باتجاه المنطقه
[موسيقى]
الجنوبيه ايش صعب صعب كثير والاصعب انك
انت ما تلاقي
جثامين كنت تجنب مواجهه عيلتي الصغير لحتى
دمعتي ما تنزل قدامهم لحتى ما افتح جرح
جديد انا حتى بتجنب كل المقابلات الصحفيه
او اجراء اي مقابلات السؤال راودني من
يومين انه بعد الحرب بعد انتهاء ضغط العمل
وهيك وقت الفراغ شو بدي اعمل شو بدي
اسوي كيف ادمنا وقت فراغي وقت فراغ كبير
حيكون ما فيش لا اخ ولا اخت ولا ام ولا اب
ولا حتى الاطفال اللي بتلعب معهم ولاد
اخوه الله يرحمه ملازمين للصلاه بشكل كبير
هم القران دائما في
ايدهم الله يتفضل ها كيف وضحته من القلب
[موسيقى]
شايف